Термін «квантова телепортація» може звучати як щось із наукової фантастики, але, як ми поговоримо в сьогоднішньому епізоді
Qiskit in the Classroom, це дуже реальна і дуже корисна техніка для квантового зв'язку та
мереж. Ласкаво просимо до Qiskit in the Classroom. У цій серії ми використаємо Qiskit, щоб дослідити деякі фундаментальні
концепції, що зазвичай розглядаються в курсах, пов'язаних із квантовими обчисленнями. До кожного відео додається інтерактивний модуль,
посилання на який є в описі нижче, тож обов'язково переглянь його. Телепортація — це вже така собі кліше з наукової фантастики та фентезі.
Людина або об'єкт зникає в одному місці й миттєво з'являється в іншому.
Як би це було круто, але, на жаль, такий вид телепортації є неможливим. Це порушило б космічне
обмеження швидкості. Ніщо не може рухатися швидше за світло. Але квантова телепортація —
можлива. У квантовій телепортації інформація, а не матерія, може передаватися між двома
віддаленими місцями. Все, що тобі потрібно, — це пара заплутаних частинок, по одній на кожному кінці, і спосіб передавати класичну
інформацію між двома вузлами. Цей протокол був розроблений у 1993 році командою
квантових вчених, включно з Charles Bennett з IBM. Вони назвали це квантовою телепортацією, тому що, подібно до
версії з наукової фантастики, квантова інформація зникала в одному місці й з'являлася в іншому, далекому
місці, жодного разу не проходячи через простір між ними. Це може звучати як магія, але, як ми побачимо, тут немає нічого
таємничого чи магічного. Це стає можливим завдяки явищу квантової заплутаності разом із класичним
зв'язком. Сьогодні ми розглянемо протокол квантової телепортації і те, як він працює. А потім запустимо його
на справжньому квантовому комп'ютері, щоб телепортувати стан qubit з одного боку квантового процесора IBM на
інший. Отже, ось як працює квантова телепортація. Припустимо, є двоє людей — Alice та Bob, які розділені
великою відстанню. Скажімо, у Alice є qubit. Назвемо його qubit Q просто для зручності. І він перебуває в якомусь
невідомому квантовому стані sq, де alpha 0 та alpha 1 є комплексними
числами. Alice хоче надіслати свій стан Bob, але вона ніяк не може фізично відправити сам qubit. Може бути,
він надто далеко, або вона навіть не знає точно, де Bob знаходиться, тому не знає, куди відправляти. На щастя,
друзі вже мають спільну пару заплутаних qubit-ів A та B, де у Alice є qubit A, а у Bob — qubit B. І
ці qubit-и заплутані. Під заплутаністю я маю на увазі, що навіть попри те, що два qubit-и розділені великою
відстанню, їхні стани корельовані так, як класична фізика пояснити не може. Ця заплутана пара —
це те, що називається Ebit, яке ми можемо використовувати як ресурс у квантових обчисленнях і зв'язку.
У цьому випадку Alice може використати EBIT як ресурс для передачі своєї квантової інформації Bob. Щоб побачити, як це відбувається,
почнемо з запису спільного стану всіх трьох qubit-ів, де я впорядкував qubit-и дещо довільно
на цьому етапі, але це впорядкування буде зручним, коли ми запустимо наш експеримент у Qiskit. У Qiskit стандартний спосіб
впорядкування qubit-ів — справа наліво. Тобто стан qubit нуль з'явиться праворуч.
Трохи розгорнемо стан і перепишемо його ось так. Тоді перший крок у нашому протоколі телепортації —
щоб Alice заплутала свій qubit даних із її половиною qubit EBIT за допомогою gate C-NOT. Gate C-NOT, або контрольований gate
буде змінювати стан одного qubit, цільового qubit, залежно від стану іншого qubit, контрольного qubit.
Якщо контрольний qubit перебуває у стані нуль, то з цільовим нічого не відбувається. А якщо контрольний qubit у
стані один, то цільовий qubit перевертається. Отже в даному випадку qubit даних Alice Q буде контрольним qubit, а
її qubit Ebit A буде цільовим qubit. Тож перші два члени зовсім не змінились від gate C-NOT, але
останні два змінились, тому що контрольний qubit Q перебував у стані один. Потім Alice
застосовує gate Hadamard до свого qubit даних Q, який переводить стан 0 у стан 1/√2 |0⟩ + |1⟩, а стан 1 у
1/√2 |0⟩ - |1⟩. Я пропущу деяку просту алгебру тут, яку ти можеш спробувати заповнити самостійно, якщо хочеш.
Але після перегрупування деяких членів ти отримаєш стан, який виглядає ось так. Тепер спільний стан трьох qubit-ів Alice та Bob
виглядає як повний безлад. Але подивись, що станеться, якщо Alice виміряє обидва своїх qubit-и. Стан трьох
qubit-ів частково колапсує до одного з цих чотирьох
членів. І в кожному випадку у Bob залишиться стан суперпозиції з амплітудами, пов'язаними з початковим невідомим станом Alice.
Пам'ятай, амплітуди — це alpha 0 та alpha 1. Тож,
наприклад, якщо Alice вимірює обидва qubit-и як нуль, то стан Bob колапсує до цього члена — початкового
невідомого стану, який Alice хотіла телепортувати. Але якщо Alice вимірює нуль на qubit A та один на qubit Q, то стан Bob —
ось цей. Цей стан можна перетворити на початковий стан qubit Q, якщо Bob
застосує gate Z, що перевернути цей знак тут. Але Bob не знатиме, що це робити,
доки не дізнається, що виміряла Alice. Тому наступний крок у протоколі — щоб Alice зателефонувала Bob і сказала йому,
які були її два виміри. Після того, як він це дізнається, він знатиме, які операції виконати зі своїм qubit, щоб він відповідав
початковому стану Alice. Ось таблиця чотирьох можливих вимірів і чотирьох можливих операцій, які Bob
повинен виконати зі своїм qubit на основі цих вимірів. Bob може застосувати gate Z, gate X, або обидва, щоб
перетворити свій qubit, щоб він відповідав початковому qubit Alice. Цей останній крок, де Alice телефонує Bob, до речі, є причиною,
чому квантова телепортація не порушує причинність. Навіть попри те, що стан Bob миттєво колапсував, коли Alice виміряла
свої qubit-и, Bob не міг отримати жодної інформації з цього стану, поки Alice не повідомила йому, що вона виміряла. А
цей дзвінок обмежений швидкістю світла. Ми щойно пройшли через багато детальної математики, тому неймовірний факт,
що ми щойно телепортували квантову інформацію, міг загубитись. Але це справді вражаюче. Використовуючи
заплутаність як ресурс, Alice могла зробити вимір, знищивши квантову інформацію, збережену в неї, та змусити її
з'явитись в іншому далекому місці у Bob. Ця відстань може бути сотні і навіть тисячі кілометрів. Ще
дивовижніше те, що цей протокол навіть не вимагає, щоб Alice знала точно, де знаходиться Bob. Поки вони мають спільний Ebit
і можуть класично спілкуватись одне з одним, квантова телепортація буде працювати. Тепер подивимось, як це працює
WEBVTT
з Qiskit і насправді телепортуємо квантовий стан на квантовому комп'ютері.
Почнемо з трьох qubit-ів — по одному для qubit даних Q та qubit-ів A і B, що складатимуть E bit. Ми
починаємо зі створення E bit. Застосовуємо gate Hadamard на qubit A, а потім gate C-NOT
між A та B, щоб створити заплутаний стан, який нам потрібен.
Потім готуємо qubit Q Alice у випадковому квантовому стані, застосовуючи випадковий унітарний оператор, показаний цим блоком з позначкою
U. Потім починається телепортація. Спочатку gate C-NOT між qubit-ами Q та A. Потім gate Hadamard на
qubit Q. Потім виміри частково колапсують стан так, що тільки qubit B Bob перебуває в суперпозиції.
Це той момент, коли Alice телефонує Bob і повідомляє, що вона виміряла. Потім Bob застосовує деякі
gate-и залежно від цих вимірів. Ці блоки з червоною рамкою позначають умовні gate-и. Перший означає,
що Bob застосовує gate X до свого qubit, якщо qubit A виміряно як один. А
другий означає, що він також застосує gate Z, якщо qubit Q виміряно як один.
Тепер у Bob має бути qubit у тому самому стані, що й qubit Alice у цьому місці тут — після gate унітарного оператора.
Якщо все пройшло за планом, то ми телепортували квантовий стан. Але як це перевірити? Ми можемо запустити той
самий circuit, але внести одну невелику зміну.
Тут ми додали ще один унітарний оператор у самому кінці circuit, застосований до qubit Bob. Цей унітарний оператор є оберненим до
того, що ми застосували на початку до qubit Alice. Логіка тут така: якщо цей перший gate створив
квантовий стан, який тепер телепортовано до qubit Bob, то цей має скасувати його, повертаючи qubit Bob назад до стану нуль.
Але, звісно, це скасовує всю нашу важку роботу з телепортації стану в першу чергу. Тому ми б не хотіли
робити це, якщо насправді хочемо щось зробити з телепортованим станом, і якщо він справді перебуває в невідомому квантовому
стані, ми не змогли б застосувати унітарний оператор для його скасування. Так чи інакше, це суто для діагностичних цілей, щоб
переконатися, що телепортація пройшла успішно. Якщо ми виміряємо qubit Bob у стані нуль, то можемо бути досить
впевнені, що телепортація спрацювала. Як тільки ми переконаємося, що наш протокол працює належним чином, ми можемо прибрати цей
фінальний унітарний оператор і насправді щось зробити з телепортованим станом. Але поки що, давай просто переконаємося, що це працює.
Виконаємо circuit на квантовому комп'ютері. Ми можемо використати Qiskit primitive sampler, щоб запустити цей circuit
багато разів і зібрати статистику результатів вимірів. Якби ми ідеально телепортували стан Alice до Bob кожного
разу, то Bob вимірював би свій qubit як нуль щоразу, але через шуми навколишнього середовища й недосконалості
gate-ів, можна очікувати деякі запуски, де qubit Bob опиняється рівним одиниці. Але поки в більшості випадків
qubit Bob вимірюється як нуль, ми можемо вважати це успіхом. Ось гістограма результатів вимірів
всіх трьох qubit-ів. Вимір Bob показаний на першій позиції кожного трибітового рядка. Як і очікувалось, чотири
результати, що відповідають його біту рівному нулю, набагато більш імовірні, ніж інші чотири. Отже, ми успішно
телепортували квантовий стан. Але подивись, як далеко ми телепортували. Ось карта всіх
qubit-ів квантового процесора, який ми використовували. І в експерименті ми використали лише ці три qubit-и.
Qubit Alice був тут, а qubit Bob — тут. Тож вони були майже поруч. Ми могли б
досягти того самого, просто застосувавши кілька gate-ів swap, які, як випливає з назви, просто міняють місцями квантові стани
двох сусідніх qubit-ів. Квантова телепортація корисна для транспортування квантової інформації на великі відстані,
і квантові стани вже телепортовались на сотні кілометрів. У наших експериментах тут ми обмежені
розміром чіпа, але ми могли б зробити телепортацію трохи вражаючішою, телепортуючи стан між двома
далекими qubit-ами на нашому квантовому комп'ютері. Спробуємо це. Ось наша нова схема circuit. Вона виглядає трохи більш
складною, але нічого принципово не змінилось, крім того, що тепер Alice та Bob створюють свій спільний EBIT,
а потім розходяться. Ця серія ліній та X позначає gate-и swap, які переміщують
стани Alice та Bob з одного qubit до іншого. Alice переміщується вгору до qubit 1, а
Bob переміщується вниз до qubit 12. Потім Alice створює свій випадковий стан на qubit 0 за допомогою
цього унітарного оператора. Майте на увазі, що вона створює стан після того, як вона та Bob вже
розійшлися. Тобто Bob вже далеко від неї.
Потім протокол телепортації продовжується як і раніше, і Bob отримує початковий стан Alice після його
умовних операцій. Ми застосовуємо обернений унітарний gate і перевіряємо, що qubit Bob перебуває
у стані нуль. І знову ми бачимо, що в більшості випадків qubit Bob виявився у стані нуль.
Тож телепортація пройшла успішно.
Хоча рівень успіху не такий високий, як коли Alice та Bob були поруч. Всі ці gate-и swap
можуть бути затратними й трохи погіршувати EBIT. Квантова телепортація може здаватись магією, але, як ми
побачили, для неї потрібні лише заплутаність, класичний канал зв'язку та кмітливість. Оригінальна пропозиція 1993 року,
яку ми розглянули у цьому відео, заклала основу для інших протоколів, таких як телепортація квантового gate,
і є невід'ємним складником для квантових обчислень і зв'язку.
На експериментальному фронті вчені продовжують розширювати межі квантової телепортації, навіть вдаючись до телепортації
квантового стану фотона між лабораторією на Землі та супутником на висоті 1400 км
над нею. І до телепортації квантових станів через шумний класичний інтернет-кабель. Якщо хочеш телепортувати свій власний
квантовий стан, переходь до модуля квантової телепортації за посиланням в описі нижче. Дякую за перегляд,
і до зустрічі наступного разу.